>>Julia: So how can we
improve it so that it's clear
that there's more than one thing?
>>Quimiah: You could just go to
the tab that says that category.
>>Student: The cats, some cats are
what makes the ecosystem healthy.
>>Julia: Awesome ideas.
We're going to share with--
>>Jessica: Because our students solve
real world problems, they see themselves
as important, thoughtful
people, who are able to grapple
with really tough problems and to
make decisions that have meaning.
>>Jeff: Our school is a preschool
through eighth grade public
charter school in Washington.
Our mission is really to help all
students develop a lifelong love
of learning.
>>Teacher: So keep cutting.
>>Jessica: Problem based learning
is at the heart of what we do.
We think that learning is really
important, but it's for a purpose,
and that purpose for our
kids is to solve some kind
of problem that's important
to them and to their lives.
>>Anne: What was the problem
we're trying to solve?
>>Student: People think that
spiders are disgusting and gross.
>>Anne: Yeah, and one of the
stories that we read about spiders,
how are the spiders portrayed, Jonas?
>>Jonas: In a horrible way.
>>People think that spiders
are like scary
or dangerous, and actually they're not.
>>Anne: We've been working on our
spider stories for quite a while,
because they are the way that
we're solving our problem.
>>Why write stories?
>>Student: It change people mind.
>>Anne: And what else can it change?
>>Student: Their heart.
>>Anne: Their heart.
>>Every student studied
their own spider.
They did research on all of
the attributes of that spider.
Then they had to take those facts
and create a story around them.
>>Sofia: The spider I've been
researching is the broad-faced
sac spider.
My story's about this little
spider trying to find a home,
and other problems it gets through
to find the perfect place to live.
>>Student: It's a daddy long legs.
>>Jonas: This writing project
is actually helping us learn how
to write better, because you
can look back at your research
and then you can know like, the facts.
>>Anne: He dove to eat the spider.
>>What I hope that I'm building
are like, tiny problem solvers.
>>Student: There was a spitting spider.
>>Anne: It's a really
appropriate way for them
to practice those lifelong skills.
>>Student: The bird didn't
see him, so he went past.
The end.
>>Jeff: When I think about how
to identify a quality problem,
I think about what is
the authentic context
that I can situate that problem within?
Our school is called Two Rivers, and one
of those two rivers is the Anacostia,
that is not swimmable or fishable.
>>Julia: Our website needs to teach
kids all about the river ecosystem.
Both its problems and how we
can make it healthy again.
>>Jeff: So they're creating a website.
>>Julia: So start to think
about this third question.
What changes can we make to improve?
>>Quimiah: We get to teach
kids about the Anacostia
and what makes the ecosystem healthy.
>>Julia: Partnering with the Anacostia
Watershed Society is giving kids the
idea that this is a real
world connection.
>>Ariel: We worked with Two Rivers.
The students are really taking part
in an authentic restoration project.
>>Bryn: I like that a
topic isn't taught to you.
You have to like, figure stuff out.
We go on field studies so we can
see what it actually looks like.
>>Solutions like rain
barrels, wetland plants.
>>Ariel: It's not like
we're looking at, you know,
what's happening with the rainforest.
Everything that they do every
day is impacting the water.
>>Student: Zoom in, zoom in.
>>Ariel: It's much more
powerful for them to be involved
in something that's part
of their own community.
>>Jeff: As kids move through our school,
they all are working
within these problems.
>>Anne: Did it make you like
the spiders a little more?
>>Jeff: Our youngest kids are working
on projects that speak to things
in their immediate environment.
>>Julia: Interesting.
>>Jeff: But as kids move
forward in class,
they work with more philosophical kinds
of problems outside of
their direct community.
>>Teacher: Is your conclusion covering
a variety of stances on gene editing?
>>Jessica: So what we want kids to be
able to do is getting in the practice
of weighing information, of
grappling with really difficult things
that don't have clear answers.
Considering different points of view,
considering different points of data,
asking for expert opinions and
ultimately coming up with a solution.
Those are things we all
do every day in our lives,
and they make our work better, so
we want kids to be able to do that.
>>Student: Hold up, guys, we have
a Twitter and Facebook and YouTube.